[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
March 3rd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
for many Americans property taxes are
going up but what if you think your
property tax bill is too high does it
make sense to push back on the numbers
Wall Street Journal personal finance
reporter Veronica dagger joins us with
questions to ask before filing an appeal
Veronica thanks so much for being with
us thanks for having me Jr so Veronica
you know the amount somebody pays in
property taxes often depends on the
assessment on their property what is the
assessment and what is it based on and
how does it figure into the tax bill the
assessment is based on multiple factors
including your square footage things
like how many bedrooms you have
amenities you have such as a pool or not
all those things factor in your
neighbors kind of what's customary for
the area also plays a part so it's
multiple things that factor into the
assessment and everyone should be
getting an assessment depending on where
you live some states reassess every year
some reassess every five years every two
years local governments use these
property tax taxes to help pay for
things like public schools and other
services and the municipality is
different how they calculate your taxes
and the frequency of Assessments really
can vary you can do a quick Google
search to see what's customary in your
neighborhood or even ask your neighbors
when to expect this but the bottom line
is when you get that assessment you want
to act quickly so what else goes into
property tax besides assessment so
there's the assessment but then there's
also the tax rate and that is set by the
municipality so you have no control of
what rate the taxing Authority is going
to tax you at and so you have to just
kind of roll with that what you can
control is how the municipality views
the value of your home that is something
that is not set in stone and that you
have some flexibility to appeal if you
disagree with now I want to get to the
appeals process in a moment but what's
the first thing that a homeowner should
do when they get their assessment in the
mail first thing open it right away I
know none of us like to see these sort
of things in the mail but go ahead and
open it review the document to make sure
the data including your square footage
lot size any amenities are listed
accurately this is so important because
if there's an error on there that can
significantly increase your property's
overall assessment and so you want to
make sure everything is on point if you
see an error bring it to the attention
of the assessor immediately each town
has their own process some people have
their process online other people need
to make a phone call to set up an
appointment the point is as soon as you
get the assessment you want to act
because you may have depending on where
you live 30 to 90 days to appeal that
assessment if you don't appeal the
assessment before you get the actual
Property Tax Bill you're out of luck for
that year oh so the clock is really
ticking here exactly you need to move
and so what happens if you disagree with
a data in your property assessment so
you might want to hire an independent
assessor to do their own valuation of
your property that's probably the most
advised way to handle this so first you
want to decide oh do I want to appeal
because I disagree then you want to say
do I want to handle this appeal myself
and spend the time and money to do that
or do I want to hire someone else to
handle that and that independent person
is an independent assessor and they are
going to review your documents take a
look at your property to see if it
should be in fact valued lower than the
assessed value if the independent
assessments show your property value is
lower than the assessed value you or
they need to request a meeting with the
local tax assessor and ask for your
property to be reassessed re-evaluated
so this is the appeals process
technically now on some occasions an
assessor might actually come to your
home how should you prepare for that so
you want to be ready when they're there
you definitely want to be in the house
to give them a tour you want to point
out things that aren't perfect so maybe
this area had some flooding or this area
is leaking or these appliances are 20
years old or this area of your staircase
is chipped and it isn't so great you
want to point out the low lights so to
speak because your goal is to get them
to assess a lower value for your home on
the flip side you don't want to make any
major improvements don't go buy and
install that Viking fridge days before
they're coming don't go doing this
beautiful landscaping project in the
front of your house before they come
save it you know wait for them to make
their assessment and then make your
changes that's really the best way to do
it now you mentioned there are some
cases where the data on your assessment
could be incorrect but in what scenarios
should a homeowner not appeal an
assessment so it's possible that
appealing your assessment could result
in you getting a higher property tax tax
bill so you don't want to appeal if that
could be the case if you're going to
appeal it's no guarantee you're going to
get a lower Bill and so get a sense of
how you compare to your neighbors if you
are paying fifty dollars more for
example in property taxes than your
neighbors it's probably not going to be
worth your time and money to appeal this
bill you actually may end up annoying
the assessor and they may say hey you
should actually be paying more so make
sure it's you know like a thousand
dollars or even more than that before
you spend the time and money and
potential headache of appealing when you
do meet with the assessor do not mention
taxes now that sounds so funny right
we're talking about property taxes but
don't mention taxes because as we
mentioned before he or she and you
cannot make a difference in your tax
rate which is factored into your
property taxes so by complaining about
your taxes the real issue of the
incorrect valuation of your property is
lost so really focus on what's the value
of my house and why should it be
different than you think it is
all right so if you don't appeal what
are some other ways to save money on
homeowner expenses you know which have
been rising substantially in recent
years they have some of these expenses
have gone up so you want to explore tax
relief programs and there's programs
that vary and type and availability
depending on the state and County where
you live some jurisdictions such as
Fairfax County Virginia or Travis County
Texas they provide relief for military
or disabled veterans or their spouses
there are several programs for senior
citizens that you want to check out AARP
has some listings on their website they
offer help for people who are looking
for it and in certain states there is
also a resource called the Lincoln
Institute property tax database and they
have a list of programs across the
country that you can search that can
help you save on your taxes all right
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance dance reporter Veronica dagger
Veronica thanks for being with us thanks
for having me Jr and that's it for your
money briefing this week your money
briefings producer is mohsin Ali our
supervising producer is Melanie Roy and
our executive producer is Chris zinsley
I'm your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
foreign